jacques sapir merci d'être avec nous
bruno le maire qui pressent la
commission européenne d'examiner les
plans de relance nationaux il y a
urgence
oui tout à fait il ya un tout à fait
urgence parce que maintenant on voit que
le retard est en train de s'accumuler
premier point il était prévu que ces
plans soient rendus il ya à peu près six
semaines la commission a donné un délai
supplémentaire parce qu'un certain
nombre de pays n'était pas prêt on
arrive là maintenant à la fin du dd on
est encore en train de soulever la
possibilité qu'il y ait un nouveau délai
parce que d'autres pays en particulier
l'italie disent que leur plan n'est pas
nécessairement bien ficelé bref il y a
un vrai problème de retard
on comprend aujourd'hui que au mieux les
premières sommes ne seront pas dégagés
avant septembre ou octobre prochain
autrement dit quinze à seize mois après
la signature du plan de relance par les
différents pays
oui il ya un vrai problème alors la
france elle table sur 40 milliards de
subventions européennes d'ailleurs c'est
beaucoup moins que l'italie dans le
gouvernement dévoilé hier une aide
européenne de 191 milliards
est ce que notre économie
elle est beaucoup moins fragilisés
finalement que d'autres pays européens
comment expliquer ces disparités
alors on est effectivement moins toucher
un peu moins touchée que l'italie c'est
tout à fait exact
nous sommes quand même très largement
touché près il suffit de regarder le
recul du produit intérieur brut en 2020
nous avons reculé de 8,2 à 8,3 pour cent
l'italie a reculé de plus de neuf
presque de 10 l'espagne a reculé de 10
bon on est en fait compris dans un
espèce de deux blocs de pays du sud qui
ont été terriblement touchés à côté de
ça l'allemagne a été nettement moins
touchées et la moyenne au niveau de
l'union européenne c'est un recul de
seulement 6 6%
donc de toutes les manières tous les
pays auront des besoins alors après il
faut regarder est-ce que quel est le
niveau de la dette est ce que certains
pays peuvent mettre de l'argent ou pas
mais globalement ce plan est en retard
ce plan est insuffisant 750 milliards
d'euros pour 457 millions d'habitants au
niveau de l'union européenne
alors que les américains pour le plan de
relance uniquement vos maîtres 2,2
trillions autrement dit 2200 milliards
de dollars pour 350 millions d'habitants
on voit bien que la le compte n'y est
pas avec ses 40 milliards dès de la
france elle doit ajouter 60 milliards de
son propre budget quels sont les projets
qui vont être financés alors sur les 100
milliards du plan de relance
on veut financer différents types de
projets des projets qui touchent au
transport des tous des projets qui
touchent au verdissement de l'économie
seulement en fait c'est pas 100
milliards qu'on va dépenser
parce que il y à toute une série de
projets qui sont concernés en fait non
pas par de l'argent frais mais pas des
déductions fiscales donc là déjà il ya
un problème
même chose on dit qu'on va soutenir les
questions de santé
mais les projets qui sont intégrés dans
ce plan c'étaient les projets qui
étaient prévus par le ségur de la santé
donc je pense que la superficie réelle
du plan français elle est plutôt de
l'ordre de 2 85 milliards pour les
dépenses d'environ 10 ont 75 milliards à
75 à 80 milliards pour les lire et les
recettes réelles
donc de toutes les manières ce plan est
déjà un plan vraiment à minima pour nous
et ça va poser un problème extrêmement
important surtout que ce plan est censé
se dérouler sur les trois ans qui
viennent
et parmi les dossiers remis à bruxelles
il ya aussi les réformes que chaque pays
s'engage à effectuer en contrepartie de
l'argent qui lui sera versée pour
relancer son économie
telle est la contrepartie que promet la
france alors la france promet comme
contrepartie effectivement de faire une
réforme des retraites qui la met au
niveau global de l'union européenne elle
promet aussi de faire des réformes
budgétaires de manière à maîtriser son
déficit
maintenant il faut dire que sérieusement
on ne voit pas la commission de
bruxelles bloquer le plan français parce
que toutes les réformes n'aurait pas été
appliquée même je dirais même si une
grande partie des réformes ne sont pas
appliquées ça c'est quand même quelque
chose dont il faut avoir conscience
conscience c'est que désormais je dirais
que là la surveillance par la commission
européenne sera relativement faible mais
c'est la contrepartie du fait que
l'effort consenti par l'union européenne
et lui aussi extrêmement faible merci
beaucoup à vous j'ai accepté je rappelle
que vous êtes économiste